Another category of connector is called the adaptor connectors.
These are responsible for putting together components that were not designed to
be put together. This often means there's some kind of translation going on.
It might be converting protocols and policies and
hence there's a conversion or transformation activity provided.
Some of the variations include invocation conversion, that is is
there a dress match, mapping? Is there marshalling, virtual memory translation,
virtual function tables? Are there conversion as far as wrappers or
packagers? Is there protocol conversion or even is the presentation conversion,
that is is the output. The actual form of the output determined by some kind of,
computation engine such as XSLT.